depuis le haut de nos plages l'image est
saisissante de part et d'autre de la
ruelle qui coule le long de la falaise
pour laisser place à la magie de ce
petit quartier de macumba des maisons
désaffectées comme des âmes en peine
ils sont pourtant encore là les
habitants de nos plages à l'image de ce
couple qui ne vit plus ici mais qui
vient chaque jour pour entretenir le
lieu un petit réconfort pour édith elle
et sa fille sont les seuls à vivre
encore ici quand le monde sont pas
mentir louis g le parti obuts japon tire
mais je voulais pas et vous partez le
coeur gros là je vois que l'eau monte
dans vos yeux mais c'est pas facile
parce qu'on a habitués de sa maison
c'est dur
revêtir au bien cette sinistrose
pourrait être vite oubliée quand on
arrive tout en bas en empruntant comme
chaque jour quasiment la petite route
taillé dans la falaise
l'uci qui levait à nos plages bas
savoure son coin de paradis
mais aujourd'hui il a un petit goût amer
ce coin de paradis je reste optimiste
mais je suis quand même perplexe dans la
mesure où depuis deux ans on avoir
personne par rapport aux instances en
fait il ya personne n'a pas
d'informations on ne sait pas exactement
ce cap des draps le quartier et ça on
essaie vraiment déploie parce que quand
même non plus nos places et j'ai bien
envie de dire nationale internationale
le projet de réhabilitation de la plage
était au départ porté par le maire de
macumba aujourd'hui cap nord a repris le
dossier et la communauté d'agglomération
n'a pas été en mesure de nous dire ce
qui finalement sera en lieu et place des
ruines de nos plages seule certitude un
projet touristique est prévue reste à
récolter les fonds pour des travaux dont
le coût pourrait s'élever à plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros